herr zastrow wir sehen die aktuellsten
zahlen und man sieht aber auch dass
diese nicht mehr exponentiell ansteigen
warum ja nun ich habe sie noch nie
exponentiell ansteigen sie das war
glaube ich von anfang an ja irgendwie
eine fehlinterpretation
aber es spielt ja keine rolle die zahlen
steigen natürlich weiter an aber die
test zahlen steigen eben auch an und was
ich jetzt ganz fatal ist und was ich ja
schon von anfang an spielt harfe im
september mal gesagt
hier die zahlen der sänger im sind
unbrauchbar
um politik zu machen daraus irgendwelche
schlüsse zu ziehen wir kriegen einfach
die zahlen präsentiert und wissen aber
gar nicht wie groß ist die bezugsgröße
also damals war es irgendwie 300 400.000
pro woche
jetzt sind wir bei 1,5 millionen aber
genau weiß das auch keiner
es wechselt ständig die zahlen und es
gibt jetzt auch überlegungen
beziehungsweise der firma weiter gereift
dass man jetzt nicht blind drauflos
testet muss man auch den biologen
vorwerfen testen testen testen das
bringt das ergebnis ja aber wen haben
wir denn getestet das wissen wir doch
gar nicht wie zum beispiel hat wissen
wir nicht wie viel symptomlos wie viel
haben leichte symptome wie viel
schwerere symptome wie finanzen
krankenhaus das einzige was wir
beschlossen die noch den situation dass
jetzt eigentlich das einzige auch da
gehört noch mal die unterscheidung dazu
wie viel davon sind oder nicht behauptet
genau so der hinweis der familien kam
von gestern auf heute haben sich 21.000
starcraft infizierten 1 ja die haben
sich nicht von gestern auf heute
infiziert das ist eine geschehen der
letzten 14 tage wir wissen gar nicht man
die leute sich angesteckt haben
die kommen jetzt auf die idee und sagen
ich geh jetzt mal hinter der eine aus
diesen der andere aus jedem grund aber
auch die sich gestern vor jetzt dann
oder 14 tage angesteckt haben das wissen
wir gar nicht und genau diese zahlen
fehlen denn nur mit den banken zahlen
brauchen oder kann man einfach keine
vernünftige politik machen wir wissen ja
gar nicht gegen was wir vorgehen sollen
jetzt haben sie es schon angesprochen
die test strategie des rk ii wird
geändert es soll nicht mehr jeder
getestet werden sondern vor allem die
risikogruppen
denn die kontakt nach vollziehung ist
einfach nicht mehr möglich gewesen es
waren zu viele menschen man hat es nicht
mehr überblicken können natürlich war es
auch an manchen orten sehr schwierig wie
genau soll das denn dann jetzt
funktionieren wir aus dem loch
herauskommen und man steckt sich doch an
und es wird noch nicht mal versucht da
die kontakte zu ermitteln
es ist ja auch schon mehrfach gesagt
worden
wir müssen lernen mit dem virus zu leben
und es ist ja auch nur nicht jede
ansteckung tödlich wir wissen natürlich
nie wie so eine krankheit dann ausgeht
aber wir müssen einfach besser vertrauen
auf unsere schutzmaßnahmen und die
schutzmaßnahmen nummer eins ist die
maske muss ich noch mal sagen da hat die
politik sich immer schwerer zahl es gibt
heute noch leute die durch die gegend
laufen und sagen wir schützen ja nur den
anderen und nicht mich und nicht sich
selber das ist kompletter blödsinn mit
der dritten müsste man den mund
verbieten weil das einfach nicht stimmt
denn die masse mensch wird die ich
natürlich viel lieber die maske
aufsetzen oder viel er die maske
aufsetzen wenn sie meist sie ist
geschützt oder sie trägt auch zum
eigenen schutz bei und nicht nur auch in
erster linie trägt zum schutz bei und an
zweiter stelle ist da noch der schutz
des anderen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren